[Music]
European said goodbye to racking up
expensive phone bills on holiday after
the Parliament abolished roaming charges
across the EU Rome like a home came into
force in 2017 enabling Europeans to pay
domestic prices while using their phones
abroad Parliament passed two major laws
aiming to reduce plastic pollution in
the European Union 40% of all plastic
production is for packaging which is why
in 2015
EU countries were required to ban free
plastic bags for shoppers or reduce the
number of bags Europeans use earlier
this year members of parliament voted to
ban single-use plastics like straws and
cotton buds from 2021 the EU
revolutionized online shopping by
banning unjustified geo blocking and
discrimination in cross-border
transactions within the EU now online
traders can't discriminate against
consumers from another EU country and
must treat them like local customers can
Europeans have it all family and a
career the European Parliament wants to
make sure they can with new rules that
improve working conditions and work/life
balance new fathers should have at least
10 days of paternity leave and
caregivers are entitled to five days of
carers leave a year in the wake of
several data harvesting scandals a
landmark shake-up of data privacy laws
came into force in 2018 the EU made it
mandatory for websites to seek consent
before using people's personal data and
companies that don't respect the rules
can be hit with a hefty fine
[Music]